will get more arguments today from house
impeachment managers
making the case against former president
trump mr trump's lawyers will begin
their defense tomorrow
nicole killian is on capitol hill with
more on the story nicole the power that
video evidence is so undeniable what's
going on what was going on in the
chamber
as it was shown because once you've seen
it you cannot unsee it
yeah that's right gail you know the mood
was very tent most senators were focused
and attentive some were visibly angry
others at the edge of their seat
a capitol police officer in the gallery
above had tears in his
eyes as some of the most brutal footage
played out
on the trial's opening day senators
heard and saw
for the first time how close they came
to danger
i'm angry i'm disturbed i'm sad it was
gut wrenching
the bravery of our police officers is
incredible
majority leader chuck schumer was among
those shown in newly released capital
security footage
being whisked away by his security
detail in another video
senator mitt romney runs after being
directed to turn around by officer
eugene goodman
the same officer who single-handedly
diverted the mob from the senate chamber
i was very fortunate indeed that officer
goodman was there to
get me in the right direction
the harrowing scenes were part of a
methodically laid out narrative of the
insurrection
through graphic details more than 140
police officers were injured
including cracked ribs smashed spinal
discs
one officer will lose an eye and
personal testimony
a terrifying banging on the chamber
doors
i will never forget that sound shouts
and
panicked calls to my husband and to my
sons
laying the blame squarely on former
president trump
donald trump surrendered his role as
commander-in-chief
and became the insider in chief
the president's legal team hit back
accusing the impeachment managers of
playing to the cameras
they're just hoping to drum up emotion
and get their last shots in at president
trump
but the managers argued the capital
attack didn't just start on january
6 but was months in the making massive
fraud claiming the former president
started and then perpetuated a big lie
of a stolen election this was not one
speech not one tweet
it was dozens in rapid succession with
the specific details
president donald j trump ran
out of non-violent options to maintain
power house impeachment managers will
wrap their presentation today one of
them told me last night that they are
proud of the team and stressed that this
is important to do
many democrats and even some republicans
say the case they've laid out so far
is powerful but keep in mind that the
former president's team still has to
make their case
and promise it will be impressive tony
i'll take it nicole thank you